when this plane flies the only emission
that comes out of its tailpipe is the
same thing that's in this glass
water it's because this plane is powered
by a hydrogen fuel cell now I'll go into
how this works in a second but what's
important is that some in the aviation
industry believe that this technology
hydrogen as a fuel could hold the key to
decarbonizing flight what we need to do
is eliminate the climate impact of
flying hydrogen looks like it can allow
us to do that but the physics and
hydrogen mean that the odds of your
future flight being hydrogen powered is
very dependent on how far you plan on
flying so is hydrogen flight here is it
in the future or is it already too late
before we get into how planes like this
work it's important to consider why the
aviation industry is thinking about
hydrogen at all in 2021 Aviation was
responsible for over two percent of
global energy related CO2 emissions with
flights pumping out a little over 720
megatons of CO2 into the atmosphere and
before the pandemic that was even higher
at over 1 000 megatons even though
engines are getting more fuel efficient
as Global Travel continues to recover
Aviation emissions are growing so in
order to hit targets laid out in the
Paris climate Accords various Aviation
groups such as iata the International
Air transport Association have set the
industry an ambitious Target net zero
emissions by 2050. while alternative
fuels like sustainable aviation fuel or
South could provide a pathway to Net
Zero as the fuel still emits CO2
hydrogen could provide a route to
absolutely zero emissions so how does it
work one method is to use hydrogen
combustion where the hydrogen replaces
jet fuel and is ignited to drive the
propellers now hydrogen is highly
flammable so while that means you get a
lot of bang for your buck almost three
times that of jet fuel by weight it also
means that its use in aviation history
has been somewhat checkered
so the other less fiery way to use
hydrogen in Planes like this is with a
hydrogen fuel cell much like a battery
hydrogen fuel cells work by creating the
flow of electrons around the circuit
hydrogen is fed into one side of a cell
the anode and oxygen into the other the
cathode with a membrane sat between the
two at the anode the hydrogen flows over
a catalyst which separates the protons
and electrons now the hydrogen protons
are able to pass through the membrane to
reach the oxygen but the electrons can't
instead they have to make their way
around a circuit and by doing so power a
motor until they can reunite with the
hydrogen protons and the oxygen to form
H2O or water which along with heat is
the only emission that comes from this
whole process and it's that exact
principle that's happening in this plane
behind me this is zero Alias test plane
a 19-seat aircraft which had its debut
hydrogen powered flight earlier this
year I caught up with zero obvious CEO
at Paris Air Show today we have four out
of top 10 Airlines as our customers
already people Reserve production slots
because they want to be the first right
now it's only this left-hand engine
that's hydrogen powered but once the
company completes testing it has plans
to develop engines to be able to carry
19 passengers around 300 nautical miles
by 2025. two other small startups
pursuing hydrogen flight a us-based
universal hydrogen who have flown a
similar plane to zero ovia and
german-based H2 fly we started in 2006
to develop this kind of Technology at
the moment we are in the seventh
generation of powertrains and I think
the technology is today here but it's
not just small startups or small
aircraft one major plane manufacturer
has thrown its weight behind hydrogen in
a big way Airbus we're hoping to
introduce a hydrogen-powered aircraft in
2035. zero CO2 so we're not just talking
about Net Zero we're talking about how
absolute zero Airbus has plans for three
different commercial hydrogen planes a
turbofan a propeller-powered plane and a
longer range and further into the future
Blended Wing design our view is that
2035 is not soon enough and we've got an
urgency to be bringing these
Technologies to Market but while Airbus
may be backing hydrogen bowing on the
other hand appears less certain about
its role in powering aircraft we've
learned a lot with hydrogen we've flown
six different forms of airplanes on
hydrogens we just think that its impact
on airplanes airports and pipelines is
greater and therefore it won't help us
as soon as some of these other solutions
that are less impactful and if the goal
is 2050 we've got to work on the things
that will help us the fastest so why is
that well while hydrogen might be one of
the most abundant elements in the
universe on Earth it's almost always
attached to something else like oxygen
to form water to isolate it requires
using an electrolyzer which is the
reverse of a fuel cell and that requires
energy now in order for hydrogen fuel to
be considered carbon neutral known as
green hydrogen the energy source that
you use in that electrolyzer also has to
be renewable like solar and right now
green hydrogen is expensive and kind of
hard to come by the different
decarbonized energies that we're looking
at are more expensive than kerosene is
today so there's going to be an increase
in price in cost of the Airlines and
that's likely to have an impact on
ticket prices then there's the
infrastructure around delivering it
while hydrogen electrolyzers can be set
up pretty much anywhere the amount
needed to power Aviation around the
globe would require investment
potentially more than other sustainable
fuels that can be piped into airports
using the same infrastructure as jet
fuel we expect that in Europe we will
have 10 to 12 billion of Euros
investment just to replace the kerosene
infrastructure with hydrogen and then
there's the plane itself while hydrogen
may be lighter than jet fuel it's
actually less energy dense and takes up
more space than the equivalent amount of
jet fuel that's why the windows on
airbus's render of their hydrogen
aircraft stop here because all of this
would be used as a fuel tank obviously
less seats means less passengers which
potentially means less Revenue once more
even with all that space right now it's
still only enough hydrogen to do short
flights meaning that transoceanic routes
aren't currently possible on hydrogen
unless it's a small ocean to really
Unleash the Power of hydrogen you really
have a huge benefit even to go long
range with hydrogen we have to rethink
the way we fly we have to rethink the
shape of the planes and therein lies the
problem when it comes to larger planes
it could already be too late for
hydrogen to take off the planes that are
on sale today by the likes of Boeing and
Airbus have a backlog of roughly six
years depending on the plane those
planes are then in service for an
average of around 20 years that means
that the planes that are being sold
today are the planes that we'll be using
in 2050 and looking around none of them
are hydrogen compatible so hydrogen in
its raw form isn't compatible with those
existing aircraft and that's why
sustainable aviation fuel is really
important there's also a chance that it
could stay that way see that Target set
by ayata and others was for Net Zero by
2050 not absolute zero and if Airlines
achieve their Net Zero aims using saf
there's questions around whether they
would then choose to invest Millions
into renewing their entire fleet to be
hydrogen planes and they've technically
already hit their environmental targets
all this means that while you may see a
greater number of hydrogen panes in the
Skies over the next few years unless
you're taking a relatively short trip
you could be waiting a long time before
you step foot aboard a hydrogen plane
foreign
[Music]